the eh-2-zed of isms utopianism
utopianism is the ism of utopias it
means a belief or interest in a perfect
world or at least a world designed to be
perfect the word utopia was coined in
1516 by Sir Thomas More writer Saint and
opponent of Henry the eighth's marriage
plans in his book of the same name
utopia has been taken by some people at
face value as a book about a perfect
land but others point to the fact that
the word utopia literally means no place
and that the book is a satire but that
hasn't stopped people through the years
there have been all sorts of ideas about
a perfect society economic utopias with
no poverty ecological utopias where
humans live in harmony with nature and
so on and so forth
many cultures and religions have a myth
of a perfect society in the past like
the Garden of Eden communes music
festivals and naturist camps could all
be seen as attempt to create a mini
utopia on earth there are many kinds of
utopias but one of the central qualities
of any utopia paradoxically is that it
doesn't exist
being a utopianist essentially means
being a dreamer when John Lennon sang
you may say I'm a dreamer in his famous
hit single and utopian anthem imagine he
was referring to exactly this quality
utopianism main-floor at its obsession
with perfection this can lead to
absurdities like the Soviet Russian
belief that one day all crime would be
eradicated because under true socialism
crime would not be necessary all the
more sinister belief in fascist
ideologies that racial purity would
eliminate all evil from society perhaps
this is why much discussion of the topic
is now confined to utopianism
dark side dystopian ism a way of
describing world's real or imaginary in
entirely negative terms from George
Orwell's 1984 to Margaret Atwood's a
Handmaid's Tale dystopian fiction has
become increasingly popular in books
films and television but interest in
utopias isn't going anywhere
references within books have been on a
steady rise since the 1900s with clear
spikes in the 60s and also up
surprisingly in the 80s and who could
deny the perfection of the
world at least in microcosm as you sit
by an ocean and listen to the sound of
the waves crushing on a beach or when
you first see a blanket of bluebells
in the spring and without at least
striving for a better world where would
we be in chains with rats chewing off
our faces
that's where
you